hängen sie mal meine frage an dich und
zwar
nein nicht eine
33 frank ersten schwere was hältst du
davon
mädchen zocken
ja es gibt außer diesen klischees
wort mädchen clans sie nur eben deswegen
ein mädchen klaren sinn weil daneben die
presse darauf aufmerksam wird weil es
halt mädchen sind gibt es halt wirklich
wenig frauen die zocken aber ich merke
schon dass das gerade in den letzten ein
zwei drei vier fünf jahren immer krasser
geworden ist also wirklich man bei giga
hatten uns noch mitgekriegt wenn man
dann auf der gamescom war oder so
umgesehen hat wäre ich quasi vor der
bühne steht und das alles guckt da waren
auch schon überraschend viele frauen
dabei aber in den letzten jahren merkt
man wirklich immer mehr also wir haben
gerade bei dem man irgendwie auf der
seite ist ein bisschen merchandise kam
so t shirts und alles und haben
natürlich ein girlie t shirts jetzt an
frauen größen gar nicht gedacht und da
kam überraschend viele anfragen von von
mädels die offenbar auch zocken und das
gucken und und hat sich irgendwelche
speziellen t shirts gewünscht haben und
daher auch dann zuerst mal gemerkt wie
viele das mittlerweile sind ich würde
jetzt mal grob so schätzen so bei uns
sonst vielleicht 30 prozent auf dem
on.de frauen die da auf die seite gehen
was schon enorm viel ist finde ich ich
glaube das wird immer mehr ist ja klar
also dass
männchen und weibchen nähren sicher
ohnehin immer mehr an und da spiele
jetzt auch so ein bisschen diesen uncool
heitz faktor und den nerd faktor
verlieren
trauen sich frauen auch eher mal ran
plus es gibt halt jetzt auch wieder mal
viel mehr casual games vielmehr spiele
auch das finden jetzt wahrscheinlich
frauen die counter strike spielen total
abwerten dass ich sage ja wegen casual
games sind mehr frauen da aber so kommt
man halt rein das spielt man dann halt
mal game dev story oder irgendeinem
kleinen mario klein oder doodle jump und
denkt sich beim nächsten mal okay
vielleicht versuche ich jetzt mal was
komplexeres deswegen ist es schon gar
nicht so von der hand zu weisen dass
eben ältere und frauen durch casual
games er zum gaming kommen was ja auch
ganz cool ist was mir auch gefährlich
wenn die entwicklung super gibt es zwei
ganz schlechte daumen nach oben und ich
hoffe dass es irgendwann halt 50 50 ist
oder sogar mehr die zweite wie ist die
arbeit bergmann und überhaupt irgendwie
so wie ihr euch in der sendung
präsentiert oder schreibt der regisseur
selbst der themenbereich ich versuche es
mal ganz kurz die zündung fährt zehn
leute davon ist die hälfte sind
redakteure die andere hälfte ist
organisation oder kamera oder alles
mögliche oder animationen und einmal die
woche setzen wir zusammen gucken welche
spiele sind da dann wird es verteilt
werden welches spiel machen der eine
redakteur macht dann ein spiel das heißt
er spielt alles ein er denkt sich die
gags aus diskutierte mit allen überlegt
sich irgendwelche popkulturellen
verweise irgendwelche mini madsen sprich
kleine filme die wir irgendwie alles
einspielen und muss all das machen also
er überlegt sich dann auch die drehs mit
den moderatoren cars kasse betreut die
dann auch beim dreh und alles da budiro
nicht auch redakteure sind müssen wir
halt auch die jede zweite woche mal
dasselbe machen und da sitzt man
tatsächlich auch echt lange so fünf
sechs tage dauerte schon das ist fertig
ist man sitze ja auch mit im schnitt man
ist bei der vertonung mit dabei man
sucht sogar jeden einzelnen sound der
irgendwas schöner machen soll selbst
raus also man hat richtig viel zu tun
schreibt auch den oft text und alles
aber gerade dass es eben von einer
person kommt die auch eine meinung hat
und die diese meinung hat auf allen
kanälen sozusagen dann transportieren
kann
ich glaube dass das ein großer teil auch
dieses erfolges ist dass man eben das
gefühl hat da ist eine meinung das muss
jetzt nicht meine meinung sein aber sie
kommt von jemandem der der zumindest
seine meinung auch vertreten kann und
die auch vertritt und oft
machen wir hier spontan auch viel also
dann oft entsteht beim dreh irgendwas wo
man sagt ey vielleicht sage ich doch
lieber das oder können wir nicht noch
den gag jeder hier weiß ja auch was man
alles machen kann mit effekten und
animationen und so deswegen kommt oft
noch was er kann da jetzt nicht noch ein
toastbrot von links nach rechts fliegen
und mir ins gesicht klatschen und da
drehen wir es halt und oft funktioniert
auch also vieles auch improvisiert
dadurch dass wir halt auch nicht angst
haben andrea ein bisschen zu
improvisieren oder oder oder was neues
auszuprobieren
was wir das getan weil ich einfach ich
oder sonst wäre
ich hab keine ahnung ja auf dich zugehen
würde und würde hey hast du mir mit cod
zacken oder irgendwann scheint
ja im prinzip alles würde mich über eine
antwort freuen und
viel spaß für wirkt blass
wir wären natürlich oft wir kriegen wir
werden wir angehören halo spielen oder
dies oder das aber wenn wir dagegen die
leute spielen werden sind auch anfangen
volland und denken weil die gewinnen und
dann verlieren sie und das ist auch sehr
demütigend deswegen haben wir genau
damit aufgehört gegen leute
in wirklichkeit kriegen wir meistens auf
die fresse und ist für uns die gegen 16
jährige mädchen zu verlieren deswegen
spielen wir nicht mehr gegen mädchen